what did you think of the show I thought
the show is very good no host no problem
no house no problems thing that moves
pretty smooth I was entertained you win
for next year though I mean they need me
what did you think of Lady Gaga and
Bradley Cooper's performance I was like
are they doing it it was so good that
chemistry was like Oscar for acting this
amazing that was hot
tonight wasn't such a great night for
women more women win won Oscars tonight
than any other time in history yeah it
was beautiful
a lot of women won and it was beautiful
I enjoyed it and I look as a woman who
works her ass off those women deserved
to win because we work hard if they care
families and all that like yeah there
was something really nice about when
Lady Gaga said she was like if you're
watching at home like it wasn't so much
dreams come true hard work persistence
dedication right never give up your
stylist lost so much tell me about the
dress is Rami kotti she's Rami Khouri
he's never nice like I'm really just
interested in always you know me I
always try to find like new emerging
designers and I want to be the first you
know fitting like what Tiffany had it
all laughs all funds and fun and games I
like to dance with everything if I can
answer that we've never loud music
cocktail champagne you know it's fine
yeah yeah thank you
[Music]